what's your view on um abortion and  accessibility  for me abortion is part of  female assigned female you know periods  in vitro birth control female  sexual pleasure menopause  birth abortion these things are all  the same women at different points in  their lives  20 of pregnancies end in miscarriage  naturally  and it's the same with abortion either  one in three or one in four women will  have an abortion in her lifetime  so i think abortion needs to be part of  the spectrum of health care that is  offered people  it is something that a woman or a  pregnant person should be able to decide  to do  with unbiased medical information if it  is the right decision for her  and where appropriate in consultation  with her partner or her god  or her family or whatever any  restrictions are only hurting poor  people